We're asked to simplify
9p to the 2/3, all of that
over the square
root of 4p cubed.
So let's just do
this step by step.
The first thing we
can do is say, well,
if it's 9p to the 2/3, that's
the same thing as 9 to the 2/3,
9 to the 2/3 times p to the 2/3.
That's what this top part
can be simplified to.
Now the bottom part, we
can rewrite the bottom part
right here.
The square root of
4p to the third.
And this is the exact
same thing as 4p
to the third to
the one half power.
This is the same thing.
The square root
of 4p to the third
is the same thing as 4p to
the third to the 1/2 power.
So given that, we can do
the same thing that we
did on the numerator,
we can say,
well, this is the same
thing as 4 to the 1/2.
4 to the 1/2 times p to
the third to the 1/2 times
p to the third to the 1/2 power.
Let's see if we can
simplify this even more.
So this is going to
be equal to-- let's
do the denominator first here.
So what's 4 to the 1/2 power?
What's the principal root of 4?
Well, 2 squared is 4.
So it's 2.
The positive root is 2, and then
p to the third, and then that
to the 1/2.
That's the same thing as p to
3 times 1/2, or p to the 3/2.
p to the 3 over 2.
9 to the 2/3.
See, the cube root of
9 isn't anything easy.
Well, actually, you could
think about it this way.
You could say it's 9 squared.
So we can view nine to 2/3.
Let me do it this way.
This is the best way
to think about it.
This is 9 to the 2/3.
One could write it.
I'm kind of making
it unsimplified.
But it will help us calculate
what it actually means.
9 to the 2/3, the
same thing as 9
squared, 9 squared
to the 1/3 power,
right, because 2 times
1/3 third is 2/3.
And you have that, of
course, times p to the 2/3.
And this is going to be
equal to 9 squared is 81.
So it's 81 to the 1/3
power times p to the 2/3.
Times p to the 2/3.
Now instead of writing this
2 and this p to the 3/2
down here, Let me just write
it as negative exponents.
Or even, let's try to
just write it like this.
But 2 in the denominator
is the same thing as 1
to the negative 1, or 1/2.
So this right here,
if I want to write
numerator, same thing as 1/2.
That and that are
the same thing.
And p to the 3/2
in the denominator
is the same thing as
p to the negative,
p to the negative 3/2.
So this whole
expression so far has
been simplified to
this right over here.
And let copy and paste.
I'll work on the next line now.
So let me copy it, and paste.
Bring it down right over there.
Let's see if we can
simplify this even more.
So let's think about 81.
Let's see if we can write
it as-- we're essentially,
when we take
something to cubed, we
take the cube root
of something, we're
taking something
to the 1/3 power.
Taking the cube root of it.
So we have to find some numbers,
or maybe we could factor it
into things that
do have cube roots,
and other things that don't.
So 81 is divisible by 3.
It's 3 times 27, which is 3
times 9, which is 3 times 3.
So 81 is 3 to the fourth power,
or 3 multiplied by itself
three times.
So we could rewrite
this 81 to the 1/3.
we could rewrite it as 3
times 3 times 3 to the-- well,
I'll write it like this.
Times 3 to the 1/3.
That's the same thing as 81.
And then let's think
about this these p's.
And I'm doing more steps than
I would do if I were doing it
on a piece of paper, because I
really want y'all to understand
kind of what's going on here.
So we have a p to the 2/3,
times p to the negative 3/2.
So that's going to be times p
to the 2/3, 2/3 minus 3/2 power.
And then so we did
the p's, and then
we just have the times 1/2.
Times 1/2.
Now this right over here,
this is the same thing.
This is the same thing
as, we could just
do this as 3 times
3 times 3, times 3.
So it's the same thing as 3
times 3 times 3 to the 1/3,
times 3 to the 1/3.
We've done this multiple times.
Times the 2/3 minus 3/2.
Let's just work that out.
Actually, three halves
is a larger number,
so let's just say it's the
negative of 3/2 minus 2/3,
which is equal to the
negative if we use 6
as a common denominator.
If we use 6 as a
common denominator,
3/2 with 6 in the
denominator, is 9/6 6 minus 4
over six that's what
2/3 is equal to.
So 9 minus 4 is 5/6, but then
we have this negative value.
So it equals negative 5/6.
So times p to the
negative 5/6 power,
times 1/2 times that
last 1/2 over here.
Now 3 times 3 times 3, or 27 to
the 1/3, the cube root of 27,
is 3.
So this right here
simplifies to three.
And then 3 to the 1/3,
that's the cube root of 3.
So we could say, 3
and then this right
here is the cube root of 3.
The cube root of 3.
So we get 3 times
the cube root of 3,
times p to the negative 5/6.
So sometimes you might want
to write the p out here
in front of the radical.
That tends to be a simpler way.
Actually, let me do that.
So I'll write the p
to the negative 5/6, p
to the negative 5/6, then
I'll write the radical.
So times the cube root of 3.
And then all that times 1/2.
or we could say all of
that multiplying by 1/2,
or just divide it by two.
And we've simplified it
about as far as you can go.
You could view it as 3/2.
You could say 3/2 is 1.5p to
the negative 5/6 times the cube
root of 3.
If you wanted to, you could
calculate the cube root of 3,
multiply that times 1/2, give
you some decimal number times
p to the negative 5/6.
And that's about as simplified
as this thing I can get.